who i smoke's got to be close to going
gold right
yeah it's approaching gold that's your
first plaque right now you have another
oh no you already have a plaque i've
seen you post the plaque before i got a
plaque i got a
plaque uh with jd young actually uh oh
what it's called what that song called
yo the op smoking music out of
jacksonville is at an all-time high
yo when i when i had the other guy here
he said in jacksonville we make op
killin music that's the genre of rap we
make do you agree with that
yeah because that seems to be like i
mean [ __ ] man it's like that and why k
osiris
it's like it's like one extreme and then
the other extreme
exactly it's so crazy now i say that and
they don't begin like that because they
know
like the whole city know that's what the
world wants so they feel that's what
they gotta do to blow you know it's like
they're leaning into it because they
feel like that's what that's what that's
what put them on
and that's on people people they want to
see bad you know what i'm saying that
and that's so crazy how the world is
like they all be trying to tell you like
oh you need to do this and do that but
then when you do this and do that they
don't show no attention yeah i'm sure no
attention this might be the best song
this might be the
well this song will probably way wrong
in this song but y'all see this because
it's just negative the controversy the
negativity so why wouldn't you
yeah you feel like you're almost
incentivized to lean into that [ __ ]
y2b5 and like i make real music